so we have a press briefing from Donald
Trump's press secretary Kaley mcenany at
the top of the hour we are expecting
questions about the completely failed
embarrassing pathetic disgraced rally
over the weekend in Tulsa Oklahoma I'm
not gonna do a lot of detail on the
rally now because like two-thirds of
today's podcast episode which we already
filmed is about the rally so I don't
want to redo this stuff I just got done
filming but we will I will take
questions about it if people have
specific questions that I'm expecting
questions here asked to Kaylee about it
of course nobody showed up they said
they had a million tickets sold 6,200
people showed up trump was furious
trump's family's furious everything
about it was completely crazy i'm only
going to show you one element from it
which is here is donald trump admitting
that he actually asked for there to be
less coronavirus testing which is murder
its murderous quite frankly it's
mathematically murderous take a listen
to this test what you do testing to that
extent you're gonna find more people
you're gonna find more cases right so I
said that my people slow the testing
down please they test and they test we
had tests of people who don't know
what's going on later the White House
realizing that that was an absolute
historic disaster and something that it
is borderline criminal for a president
to admit they said oh he was joking guys
what is wrong with your sense of humor
that you can't tell this was an obvious
joke come on he was kidding around he
was completely kidding around
okay now I'm an idiot and that we want
to try to avoid that so anyway the maybe
the word are in fact let's look at
Arizona coronavirus cases maybe the
worst it almost seems fake maybe the
worst place in the country right now is
Arizona it could be the worst place in
the world actually there that I saw one
study that said if Arizona were a
country it would be the country with the
worst growth
rate for cases in the world Trump has a
rally tomorrow night in Phoenix okay so
that tells you just about everything we
need to know and I will probably be
covering that one live I was away over
the weekend so I didn't cover the tool
so rally live but I will probably cover
cover Phoenix live and we'll have a
pre-show and maybe we'll take phone
calls it'll be and it'll be an entire
thing so that's what's going on there
and then beyond that I will take I'll
take questions on the rally but we spent
so much time on it today on the show
that for those of you who are subscribed
to my podcast you're gonna get that
episode a shot out of a cannon in about
an hour and 45 min 2 hours and 45
minutes so I won't i won't redo that
right now okay people getting the
banhammer dropped on them already over
on youtube that's great to see the
moderators are not sleeping they are
very very much paying attention mart
Fillion says via super chat my
grandmother used to say that bitten by a
dog or a [ __ ] hurts the same oh my god
meaning that whoever you vote will
result in the same thing but having said
that I have a feeling that the Biden
bite will hurt less oh boy Marty you've
got a lot going on over there so that is
that is quite a statement to make elias
Chavarria also says advice for new
students attending university in the
fall I mean you'd have to tell me more
about whether you're starting in a
distance mode or or what's going on I've
actually started getting actually should
I do this now I'm in a wait so so I
thanks to popular demand
I'm now on cameo and I got some
interesting advice questions over the
weekend and I'm gonna play one of my
cameo answers I'll tell I'll talk about
that a little bit momentarily and Matt
Chavez says via super chat thanks for
reminding me David I can't leave my home
yeah it's it's what's happening in
Arizona is absolutely crazy let's see I
wanted to get an update on Florida or
Florida depending on what part of the
state you live in
oh very very ugly and then how is Texas
doing Texas not looking good and then
how about Okhla
home ooh oh my goodness
Oklahoma doing terribly and then
Arkansas I heard is bad okay Arkansas is
not as weaponized and then Alabama I
thought okay and then how is
Massachusetts doing by the way now gotta
be pleased with that got to be pleased
with that very much so and both of these
spikes were were actually blips when a
bunch of cases were retroactive Lee
added so I mean listen we have a
Republican governor and he's mostly
doing a good job I don't I mean I have
no interest in playing partisan politics
he's a Republican we have a very left
legislature and he's he there are some
criticisms you could make of Charlie
Baker but he's been doing pretty well Oh
somebody's asking me about Ohio let's
take a look Ohio okay Ohio's holding
steady it's not an ugly curve
necessarily they're not improving
dramatically but I mean you know when
you compare to a place like for example
Switzerland you see really how much
we're failing I mean look at that
that's just this is unheard of in the
United States it's just not happening
it's just not happening okay we're
standing by for Cayley McKenna and Annie
at the top of the hour I expect she will
be presented with any number of nasty
questions related to the failed Trump
rally Donald Trump is extremely
triggered and it's going he's going to
remain very very triggered and as you
can see you know he the only case he was
really able to make at the rally was
Biden his bad and he can drink water so
I mean look he will always stand against
socialism that so there's no threat of
socialism in the United States you know
everything everything is just a joke and
one of the things I'm focusing on today
oh my God look at this that I'm focusing
on today's podcast is that he's not
presenting a coherent case for
re-election if he runs on the same stuff
he ran on in 2016 it exposes that he
didn't do it if he runs on Biden is bad
that hasn't worked particularly well in
the past so that's gonna be a big topic
coming up this week as well Jacob Ratner
says via super chat what are your
thoughts on Trump saying he slowed down
oh we just did that okay incredible
TV says I know you probably covered the
water sippin moment at the rally on your
show today can't wait to hear your
thoughts on it yes so some of you may or
may not know that we do in our pot audio
podcast every day some people call it a
POG cast but that's not I would never
call it that and it's available every
day at 3:30 to everybody if you just
subscribe to my podcast on you know
iTunes stitcher Spotify Pandora
iHeartRadio Google Play whatever and you
don't have to wait for all the clips to
publish on YouTube if you don't want a
lot of people love the audio podcast
format so to speak let me say thank you
to Shane Trimble Shane is new member
number one today
uno number one at join pakman.com very
much appreciate that want to say thank
you to alumnus for subscribing over on
Twitch as well as gazer gazer peg lop
gazer pug lop
that sounds unintuitive but it is what
it is
thanks to gazer plop for subscribing for
three months with twitch prime my plan
for this week is tomorrow evening I will
do a pre-show on all platforms before
the Trump rally we will cover the Trump
rally live and then my thought is if we
have a nice stream without too much
anti-semitism I will after the Trump
Phoenix Corona rally pinch off all
streams other than twitch and open the
phone lines wide open on Twitch that's
my thought that's my thought as of right
now a 4:00 tomorrow night okay other
Super chats coming in fancy sloth says
Newton North Carolina is really bad
we've more than doubled our numbers in
less than a month love the show shoutout
to DG G let's see how let me see here
how is North Carolina doing North
Carolina yeah it's not good it's
definitely not good you're right North
Carolina South Carolina also neither one
is doing particularly well oh Lisa
medulla
I hope that got it right this time oh
Lisa medulla Okafor says good to hear
from you David look forward to
calling your show again soon keep up the
good work brother thank you my friend
oh as we can more accurately call him I
believe the correct pronunciation is
Alisa medulla Oh calls into the show
he's called in a few times and his calls
are his calls are solid very very solid
thanks to Malcolm Andrews who is new
member number two today at join
pakman.com appreciate that ok I am going
to play I don't know how many of you saw
this but we published a video yesterday
of me absolutely dominating a strawberry
that I grew in my garden so for people
who didn't see this if you followed me
or the david pakman show on instagram
you would have seen this earlier than
anybody this is now if there are any
rugged individualists conservatives and
in the audience i do want to warn you
what this video contains is such extreme
alpha male behavior that you may be
triggered ok you may be triggered and
this is extremely me mobile we have any
number of memes that have already been
made and submitted to our subreddit so
let's take a look this is a special
presentation of the david pakman show I
grew an entire meal ok grew it the
testosterone is off the charts here take
a look at this I've got my strawberry
bush and one ripe strawberry
oh and one second let's make sure that
we are in HD we need powerful HD here
here we go
look at this thing
look at that
I'm gonna get one leaf of mint there we
go to have with my one strawberry I'm
not a savage I'm not gonna just have
unseasoned strawberries I'm gonna throw
some mint on I've got my red organic
wild strawberry and a single piece of
fresh cruelty-free mint which I'm now
going to try okay pause it now a bunch
of people interestingly you never know
what people will fixate on in the
comments but a bunch of people were
saying that clearly I've been to
finishing school because my utensil
technique is so proper which is an
interesting thing I mean I know that
there's a lot of cultural baggage loaded
loaded in such a claim but it's
interesting that that's something people
fixated on from this moment based on how
I was holding my utensils which is not
something that would occur to me boom
supple spicier than I expected very good
really really good one more piece you
have to get the right amount of mint on
each bite I think people are some people
are saying in twitch that I cut it as if
it were like a thick steak and that
that's maybe what's funny about it that
that may be the case something kind of a
flat area where it was up against the
soil
hard to be really hard to be gotta give
you the wipe and by the way for people
saying that why am i wearing a bib it
this is all for the camera okay it's all
it's just a joke guys let's all relax
but a beautiful fillet of strawberry
there and much more where that came from
on my Instagram which is David Pakman
and the show Instagram david pakman show
so people did like that it's wholesome
content and for anybody who felt
emasculated by that alpha male behavior
apologies in advance apologies in
advance also yes this is we're gonna get
off of Instagram in a moment I did post
a picture of myself on my Instagram see
if people can see that with an even
tinier puppy that I found so if you want
to see that that's a David Pakman okay
we're done with Instagram for the day
thanks to zambese cam Roy and log on PC
log on PC over on Twitch saying poo poo
[ __ ] is dummy dumb dumb I don't like
that I don't like any attacks on people
that I know but appreciate the support
very very much do you do what should I
read some super chats or do you guys
want to see one of the cameos that I did
over the weekend to somebody who needed
dating advice or charisma advice which
what do people want to see first I'll do
both of them but somebody wants super
chats cameo dating advice cameo cameo
cameo supple okay alright people want
came okay we're I'm gonna get back to
super chats momentarily alright so
here's the deal
a bunch of people particularly people on
YouTube and twitch oh wait hold on a
second where is this oh yes told me to
get on only fans and on cameo now it
seems only fans is kind of like a porn
thing so I didn't do that
but I did make a cameo account and I
have not promoted it at all yet and
hilariously over the weekend I started
getting a whole bunch of what Paul that
second oh my god this everything's going
wrong hold on a second I apologize let
me
let me reset it over the weekend I
started getting a bunch of like Father's
Day requests about cameo can you send a
shout-out to my dad you know my dad
loves this my dad loves this sort of
stuff like that which was great
I got a hilarious one from someone whose
friends spent 600 bucks on an online
charisma class and they asked me
essentially to tell them that it was a
waste of money
so let me riku this here we go which I
did alright so we're gonna take a look
at this now here is me and you I guess
people are interested in this stuff I'm
on cameo dot-com slash David Pakman if
you want me to send your friends
messages like this I I'm available so
let's take a listen to this one hey Matt
so I heard from Casey that you spent
$600 on an online charisma class now
maybe you're very wealthy and if that's
the case that's fine but in my
experience you can find a lot of that
material for free and I would even be
glad for you to call into my show when
I'm taking live calls and talk about
what I'm told is maybe a desire to
improve some dating skills okay so with
total peace and love if you want to
figure out a way to get on my show you
can email me through my website we'll
figure out your phone number so that we
take live calls I see your number pop up
we can talk about what's going on it's
free
no $600 for an online charisma class and
hopefully hopefully you'll come away
with something just as valuable okay so
I want to hear from you there you go so
if there it is that's an incredible
message of peace love and inspiration -
Matt from Casey and I was wearing scrubs
I just come in from my shift at the
hospital no it was just a t-shirt so
anyway I honestly I don't really know
what to make of this entire cameo thing
so far like I got I didn't promote it
and I got four requests for silly little
videos and a fifth one that was so
outrageous that I had to decline it I
didn't do it but I don't know we'll see
what happens it could be a source of
Mima bull material and I am let me see
what am I
I am David Pakman on cameo in the app
and I guess I'm also at cameo comm slash
David Pakman so that's that that's
what's going on okay other Super chats
are coming in let me see here hold on
I'm missing a bunch of okay tanner
cap Hannah glue says hey David can you
comment on the Kentucky Democratic Party
for example who you support and why also
love the D Pakman chess tournaments I
don't know enough about the primary I'm
going to be supporting whoever wins
tomorrow's primary period one two one
click bezel says thanks for what you do
DP I'm in Kansas here mask-wearing is
nil people acting like things are normal
Little League baseball exasperated
that's horrifying
Elias Chavarria says some classes are
online or remote others are in-person my
issue is that tuition is the same and
they won't say they're moving fully
online you know that's a bigger issue
that I'm really able to address but I
know of a lot of people that are furious
that their their school has gone remote
and yet they aren't getting any discount
even though they're not doing room and
board and that strikes me as unfair it
strikes me as unfair mark Fillion says I
thought the last Super chat was supposed
supposed tongue-in-cheek okay I have no
idea what's going on
Anna Burgos says hey David what do you
think contributes to New York success
regarding coronavirus could it be that
they've reached hurt immunity no if that
is not it if you look at the antibody
tests they have certainly not reached
herd immunity incredible TV says your
strawberry to Mint ratio is off David
you might want to use a scale next time
yeah I needed dramatically more
dramatically more mint
I think we're standing by for Kaylee
maggin Annie let's make sure that we are
fully an HD and everything is good to go
here excellent
Monty Marmite says you're a comedy
genius and always crack me up but don't
let this go to your head and thereby be
changed by it stay pure you beautiful
alpha warrior okay thank you Matt Chavez
says a chef's knife would have made it
funnier you know I said when I was
filming it I said to my girlfriend this
would be funnier if I use a gigantic
chef's knife
she did not think it would be funnier
and I don't know why I mean her her
specialty is not comedy I don't know why
I listen but I did I thought a chef's
knife would have been funnier thanks to
Laura Smith Greyson for the YouTube
subscription men without ties says that
face zoom and killed me somehow both
incredibly endearing and also
threatening yeah let's just look at that
moment again real quick I think that the
zoom in is a key moment
yeah that was the idea what are one of
our colleagues Noah put together the
edit and I like the way it turned out
very very much let me say thank you to
Michelle Adams whose new member number 3
and also Brent Gwynn Brent Gwynn who is
new member number 4 today at join
pakman.com very much appreciated we are
getting ready soon to probably wind down
this coupon code but we will have a new
one but at least from the standpoint of
today membership remains the best way to
support our work the podcasts the
YouTube clips the streams the phone
lines everything
the strawberries it's all funded in some
way I guess by membership if you grab a
membership at join pakman.com I will
thank you during the stream ok we have a
goal of 25 we are 4 out of 25 4 out of
25 if you want an obscene discount that
would be illegal in a lot of the
southern states that are riddled with
coronavirus the coupon code 2020 now is
an extreme discount code and I'm glad
for you to use the code or don't use it
whatever fits your financial situation
and of course with the code we're
talking about a $2 a month membership if
you pay for the year you're talking
about a dollar eighty so it's a
beautiful thing ever I promise you
everybody who signs up during the stream
will get a thank you from me and it will
be extremely exciting for me I can't
speak about the rest of the audience
other super chats coming in Sofia Rose a
has subscribed on YouTube I see dead
llamas says hey David random bit of
older but good news North Dakota native
tribes won a lawsuit that was causing
voter disenfranchisement back in
February thank you very good news I'm
not familiar with that
Sam Kareem says thoughts on Lauren
southern going the centrist route I
don't know anything about it I don't I
have not seen anything she's done for I
think years at this point thanks to John
Valjean or Valjean for the twitch Prime
subscription I
preciate that also thanks to crimson
Elric for the 9-month twitch
subscription says hey David keep it up
and be well and also thanks to Margot
Cabot or Cabo who has subscribed for
four months Mart Fillion says the one
about the dog and the [ __ ] ah got it
okay
Robocop says did you wash the strawberry
you alpha male I did so you could
probably tell that here this the point
of the strawberry has some soil on it
but then if you look along where's the
zoom in if you look here that dirt is
all gone because through the magic of
editing I did run it under some cold
water fresh cold water wild cruelty free
water and the the strawberry was
perfectly cleaned by the time that we
got to it okay people I washed the mint
as well people asking about the coupon
code it's right above my head okay where
it says coupon code above my head that's
where the coupon code is and it's in
blue text two zero two zero now that's
the that's the coupon code and there it
is nasty questions wants to know if I've
streamed Trump rallies in the past
tomorrow will be my first with you love
what you do is always I've I during the
primary I dipped in and out of Trump
rallies at the same time that Bernie
rallies and other rallies were going on
I've never just done a trump rally event
so I think the plan for tomorrow night
will be will do a pre-show we will watch
the rally and then depending on what
happens we will do live phone calls over
on Twitch that's my thought right now
Shawn M says David would you regret a
Biden presidency if it resulted in a 30%
drop in your business revenue it's not
going to so I'm going to do what's right
for the country which is to vote for
Biden but Biden's presidency will not
drop my revenue 30% it it could slow the
growth but the sacrifice I'm more than
willing to make for the good of the
country
the good of the country my friends let
me say thank you to Trevor Yarnell
Trevor is new member number five today
at join pakman.com also thanks to
Kathleen Duncan whose new member number
six and Clayton Baker Clayton is new
member number seven not 76 look at that
that was crazy
we're standing by for Kaley maghen Annie
sometimes the Fox stream doesn't
immediately start when they go live but
they did announce that it would be 1
p.m. so probably within the next couple
of hours my guess is that it will start
over on Twitch Justin D winters and
brainteasers
are sending cheers also keep rollin
rollin rollin yo has subscribed with
twitch prime yeah that's a joke I mean
listen it was scheduled to start five
minutes ago they tend to start late but
hopefully not super late today because
because they and they only announced it
recently so it should be relatively soon
I'm hoping 1,200 people waiting to watch
on Fox 4500 watching on the White House
feed so what yeah we'll see what it ends
what it I I'm my real goal is to see how
what propaganda they have lined up to to
explain away the disaster of the Tulsa
Oklahoma rally on Saturday and maybe
they will be asked questions about the
wisdom of having a rally tomorrow night
in Phoenix Arizona given that Arizona
appears to be the world hotspot at this
point Arizona and Brazil are like the
two worst places to be globally right
now for coronavirus so it's going to be
it's gonna be wild
thanks to nug Wrangler for subscribing
for 10 months with twitch Prime which I
very much appreciate it the hill is live
people are saying okay let's see the
hill YouTube channel let's see if we can
find there live stream or life stream is
some like to call it alright here we go
that was the wrong link the hill live
YouTube what's going on here okay got it
and got it very very good but we got an
outgoing alright yeah so it seems that
we've got a number of different streams
here so as soon as this starts we should
be able to see there it is beautiful
alright we are in the room looks like
people are relatively close to ready so
it should be starting very soon let me
say thank you to jonathan chevre a who
is new member number 8 today at join
pakman.com and durham knight cyl is new
member number 9 Sean O'Reilly is new
member number 10 really appreciate the
support guys very very much so
I see people want to see the cameo video
again i-i-i showed the cameo video once
already you want to see the cameo video
again just find it on my cameo I don't
think we need yeah I'm not gonna play it
again right now especially when it looks
like things are close to getting started
other super chats that are coming in
Kevin Thomas Thomason Thomason says
hello from Sweden have you ever heard of
Swedish PM Ola Olaf Palme a Democratic
Socialist in my opinion the greatest we
ever had in Sweden a true inspiration
I've no I don't really know too much no
I would have to research that connor's
it Trower says what are your thoughts on
Andrew you hang I think he probably is
not gonna have the nomination wrapped up
anytime soon but I like him a lot
he has been on my program a couple of
times and he's a good guy
juicy bacon 12 says Trump tweeting
laying the groundwork to deny the
election yeah I think that there's a
very good chance Trump will call the
election rigged he'll still leave but
but he will call it rigged remember that
no matter what Trump says on January 21
if he doesn't win re-election in
November he's just not the president he
no longer has presidential power at that
point and that's an important thing to
always remember
marika says will you cover the
humanitarian crisis in Yemen I know
there's a lot going on in the US but
Yemen is really bad
yeah I'm not against covering that you
know we've talked about the humanitarian
crisis in Yemen it's there there's it's
not changing so dramatically that I feel
like there's something new to talk about
it's a disaster there it has been so I'm
not certainly not against covering it
but something I am always paying
attention to that's for sure let me say
thank you to Gerald Acton whose new
member number 11 today as we wait for
Kaylee also Cheryl Schneider just
upgraded her membership doubling the
membership so I'm an accountant we're
counting at all it all counts today
because it's a very special day mr.
lieutenant pink says any thoughts on the
calls for a so-called green recovery
from kovat yeah I mean listen if there
is anything sometimes these calamities
are opportunities to rethink structures
that we take for granted the term
path-dependent monopoly is a relevant
term here which maybe I'll explain on
the program at some point soon so so
much horrible is happening but if we
were logical and grin like a normal
country hopefully we would say here's an
opportunity to as we reopen and fix
things fix them in a way that's more
sustainable both from an economic and
environmental standpoint I mean look at
who's president I don't think we're
going to do it if Biden replaces Trump
because we will still be in coronavirus
recovery in 2021 hopefully we will be in
recovery rather than still in the throes
of it we will very much have the
opportunity to recover in a greener way
it's a job in the current administration
there's just no chance it's just not
happening
mr. Mosely says Trump will blame
protesters for the rally failure yeah
they've already tried that I mean it's
just it's pathetic it's pathetic
team the band says irrelevant but on an
unlimited budget what kind of drums and
cymbals would you buy I don't know I
don't even know what's popular right now
I'd have to really I'd have to really
give that some thought
makaula Michaela has subscribed at the
SOI boy level on YouTube I also want to
say thanks to Eric Lidell who is new
member number 13 lucky 13 today at join
pakman.com there seems to be some
confusion in the chat about whether I
now have an only fans I do not have an
only fans okay I have a cameo here is my
cameo I am David Pakman on cameo as you
see I got a review absolutely perfect
David keep up your great work amazing so
I'm on cameo oh my god I must have
filmed this before my haircut and shave
I look 15 years older in this video
that's crazy but I am NOT on only fans I
apologize I am NOT on only fans okay
thank you - cyntha Tron who has
subscribed with prime and Joyce 1964
appreciate that
Arun Mehta says could a bad brexit deal
also hurt Trump I don't think so I mean
we've got four and a half months left
until the election there is so much bad
happening here that I don't I don't
think Trump is particularly going to be
affected I mean it's like we have so
many economic problems we have nearly
20% real unemployment
it's so insane here that I don't know
that brexit is really gonna factor to
any significant degree in Donald Trump
getting elected or booted out in
November
let's see some people saying I should
have an only fans listen I don't have an
only fans and I'm not going to have an
only fan so it's it's cameo and that's
it
that's all there is my friends nothing
else yes I will be streaming the Trump
rally tomorrow night I hope that you
will join me we will have a pre-show we
will stream the rally and then maybe I
will open up the phone lines that's my
thought for tomorrow Wednesday we will
see what happens oh we're about to get
an ad here
let's switch away from it this still
hasn't started so
fact that box is still not live in the
room and neither is the White House
signals to me that we may weep this made
there may be a delay if we see everybody
walk out of the room we will know that
that there is one okay very good
who else is sending super chats here
Jacob Ratner says if Trump wins
re-election how far will the US fall
very very far it's gonna be the first
term will be child's play compared to
the second term put it that way
Katy cot says regarding your strawberry
adventures try black pepper on them
sounds weird but tastes great oh I would
not doubt that I actually like black
pepper on papaya I don't know if any of
you have had papaya but it's pretty good
with black pepper
how do people send super chats that kind
of are like a brighter CEO this is a
brighter white text that happens every
once in a while and I never understand
how and it's kind of blinking as well
anybody knows how to do that
Vincenzo dukes says petition to change
our label from soy boys to strawberry
and mint boys yeah we should have a
strawberry and mint membership level
it's an idea
Walt spends says David my concerns have
always been the debates Joe did better
than expected in the last debate against
Bernie do you think Trump has any chance
to get any bounce from the debates at
this point
yeah debates are unpredictable because
you know Joe Biden seems to have better
in worst days Donald Trump you know it
could be upper Trump it could be down or
Trump the one that's you know hunched
over the podium sweating visibly and all
of that stuff so there's definitely the
the real possibility of the debates
going one way or the other it could it
could really help or hurt either
candidate and by the way no debates have
been scheduled and we're going to have
to see what even is put together as far
as that goes
el McVicker says Trump is tweeting right
now in real-time that the election is
already rigged he's already prepping to
lose and it honestly looks great on him
yeah he's going to stay or or he's
trying to use that to justify staying
right it's one or the other
I believe Trump will say it was rigged
but we'll leave that's my belief
as of right
thanks to Jacqueline Muller Jacqueline
Muller is new member number 14 today at
join pakman.com really appreciate the
support thank you
a couple people said that the coupon
code is not working it is it is as you
can see 14 people have used the coupon
code the coupon code is in blue text
above my head it is 2 0 2 0 n no W the
code works my friends the code works and
folks are using it right now people
wondering if in my strawberry video I'm
discriminating against basil because I
used mint in my meal no I have actually
let's see if you can even see it because
I have a mint plant right next to this
one no you can't really see it I would
consider doing a garden tour like a full
garden tour and show everybody my cukes
and all of that stuff maybe so I would
consider it at some point
thanks to not my corn who has gifted a
subscription over on Twitch
I actually I have let me talk about
twitch just momentarily twitch has been
fantastic for us lately twitch has been
so good you know we don't have the
biggest following on Twitch in that I
have just shy of 37 thousand followers
on Twitch and I've not been on twitch
for that long as many of you know you
know our YouTube channel has been going
on for eight years or longer I've only
been on twitch 10 months but the the
twitch audience has been absolutely
fantastic relative to the followers we
get a lot of viewers on Twitch and we're
gonna keep doing twitch exclusive stuff
and taking calls on twitch and I'm
looking at doing some more live Simon
Kenneth destiny Bunnell ii on the other
day.i I would actually I sent Hasan
Destiny [ __ ] ii a message the other day
trying to get him on my stream he good
he ghosted me he didn't even respond and
i hope he's not mad at me I hope because
I I just that would be horrible but I
would love to
have Hassan back on anytime I haven't
talked to him for a while
I would love to do a simultaneous karu
Nakamura who has exploded I would love
for him to coach me to not be so
pathetically bad at chess yeah so anyway
if anybody in my twitch audience has
contacts with other twitch streamers
that you think I should be doing
Simon's with please help coordinate
I always appreciate that stuff Zoomer
media has just subscribed with prime and
it's all very very exciting what's going
on that's that's for sure
thanks to Sheryl Rosen by the way Sheryl
you are new member number 15 today at
join pakman.com other super chats that
are continuing to come in let's see Mart
Fillion says funny that during the
stream they run an ad for the epoch time
yeah I don't as you all know I don't
have any control over the YouTube ads so
all sorts of wacky ads show up all the
time Giovanni Diaz has subscribed on
YouTube Laura Smith Grayson says where
can I see your strawberry video I want
my sister to see it okay so it's on
YouTube on YouTube it is called
strawberry gets absolutely dominated so
if you just and if you just search
YouTube for David Pakman strawberry it
is the first video that comes up oh wow
if you search for straub david pack on
strawberry you get strawberry gets
dominated my channel and then my drip my
to joe rogan appearances that's
interesting I wonder what about the
algorithm thinks that if you search for
David Pakman strawberry you want to
watch Joe Rogan that's interesting very
interesting fluid it says David how
about a triple stream with Hassan and
destiny tomorrow night listen I'm gonna
be totally honest with you guys I'm
friends with Hassan destiny [ __ ] the
second and I'm friends with Stephen
Kenneth destiny Bunnell the second they
are not friendly with each other right
now and I think that that's not good
we went to LA we had a beautiful evening
we had a perf
picked dinner with with with Destiny's
significant other I don't I don't know
what they're doing in any way and it was
great and we we ordered Indian food and
all sorts of stuff and now they're
beefing with each other sadly I would
love to bring them back together or if
nothing else at least moderate a
conversation where maybe we could talk
things out I think it would do
explosively well on all platforms so if
people can help me line that up I would
love to do it I think if I go to them I
don't know that they're gonna be
interested in me moderating maybe a
meeting of the minds to get everybody
back back in touch but I would love to
do it I think it would be really great
and they are two friends of mine and it
would be fantastic
okay let's see Bryan Holaday says caps
protest was not taken seriously four
years ago given the rise of black lives
matter in 2020 do you think he should be
up for an award like the Nobel Prize the
Nobel Prize maybe listen III think that
Colin Kaepernick's kneeling protest the
idea that given everything that's going
on with violence and intimidation and
police brutality oh it's something
starting here hold on a second I just
heard something no I do not the idea
that it's it's offensive for Colin
Kapernick to kneel it's a joke right it
seems pathetic it's so obviously an
offensive what's next for him you know
Nobel Prize I don't know I don't know
who's in the running so many people have
done such great things so I wouldn't
really be able to comment on that donor
14 says hey David could you give a
breakdown on what happened to the
Kentucky polling sites I have a story
coming out about that tonight on YouTube
and on my podcast and so I'm gonna try
to avoid like redoing content that I've
already recorded for the podcast but if
you're subscribed to my podcast you'll
have my full analysis of Kentucky in
just an hour and a half or so thanks to
Nancy 'krsna rich Nancy Krishna rich is
new member number 16 today
and Seifert is new member number 17
today and Sheila Bell is number 18 very
interesting thing I've observed I want
to get your your insight on this in
general we have a much larger male than
female audience on the show it's common
for most shows like ours you know the
Young Turks majority report etc and we
have way more male members than female
members during the streams I get so many
more female subscribers I don't know why
I don't know what explains it but it is
it is a reality and I'd be very
interested in hearing from people in the
audience why that is
nobody knows okay very good I guess we
will see Conner
zit Trower says Trump / Hitler
comparisons listen
Trump's his own thing and even if we can
identify elements of Trump that are
reminiscent of pre-world War two Germany
Trump is his own uniquely bad thing I
don't think we really need to talk about
Hitler to make the case that Trump is
bad and Trump needs to go III just don't
it doesn't seem to me to be the most
important comparison to make or or the
most important approach people are
telling me to check out the cameo
requests that they sent me let's see if
it's anything really bad okay yeah I'm
not I'm not doing like I'm not doing
intimacy advice there's people okay oh
boy okay this is clever for sure so I'm
now on cameo and someone just sent me a
request for like extremely specific
intimacy related advice related to some
products that people can buy for certain
intimacy issues I'm probably not doing
that I I've been doing most cameos so
far I think I did like all but one from
what people requested but there's some
stuff where it really doesn't seem like
it's to my advantage to have videos
floating around the internet so I I'm
doing I'm doing most of the cameos
that I'm being asked to do but it is of
course at my discretion it is at my my
discretion thank you thank you very much
appreciate it
left is best Matthew's says why do you
think destiny hates Michael Brooks he
set it on your live stream with you Kyle
and Michael are very smart individuals
yeah I have no idea yeah he didn't go
into detail about that so I have no idea
okay it looks like things are about to
start
we will now switch over to the Fox
stream which seems to be going oh and we
now have the Whitehouse stream very very
good okay so we might we might actually
be very close to things getting started
and that would be good I am mostly going
to be paying special attention to what
sort of propaganda BS descale II have
prepared related to the failed rally in
Tulsa and tomorrow night's rally in
Phoenix remember Arizona arguably the
global hotspot right now and that's
where Donald Trump is going tomorrow for
a for another one of these Corona
rallies so very very bad stuff and I'm
looking forward to the spin the spin a
beamer boy has just subscribed on Twitch
for the second month in a row I
appreciate that thank you very much
people asking again if the coupon code
still works yes it does as you can see
here 18 peep oh no the stream is
buffering we don't want that
the the Whitehouse stream often buffers
I'm gonna stick over here on on Fox News
for now yeah 18 people have used the
code website memberships are the number
one way to support our work and we have
a goal of 25 the coupon code is right
above my head it's 20/20 now it works
you've just got to type it in correctly
that means all lowercase and no spaces
it is working it is working very very
powerfully my friends I do read the
twitch chat a common question a lot of
people desperate for me to notice them
I'm noticing you I'm noticing you
everybody relax
Anthony Lujan
says hi David thoughts on Robert rice I
subscribed to his channel and enjoys
content but your opinion is my boast
valued he's very good he's excellent
Robert ray she's excellent Jim Clarke
has sent a twenty dollar super chat with
no question or comment just supporting
thanks Jim very much appreciate that we
are standing by for the start of this
Corona briefing now this is not it the
only Corona element of this is that
Trump had a rally in Oklahoma a
coronavirus hot spot and then has a
rally tomorrow night in another
coronavirus hot spot so that's that's
really the that's really the news people
asking how many twitch subscribers I
currently have six 3600 and note sorry
631 thanks to under P know under P no
yeah so I've got that going for me I
mean that's definitely something guy
just took out a remote that was
interesting I don't know what that was
about
it feels like we're very very close the
White House feed still buffering but it
feels as though we are going to be
getting started
extremely soon extremely soon insight of
the ages asks any interest in talking
about black Wall Street white Dems ended
that town black GOP started those towns
I have talked about that actually and
I'm certainly open to talking about it
more or again thanks to midnight Hayes
who is twitch subscriber 6:32 also
thanks to Brandon Johnson who's number
19 today at join pakman.com very much
appreciate it I expect a very short
presentation from Kaylie mcenany and
then a few questions he or she is let's
get started
[Music]
hello everyone
this past Father's Day weekend we saw
violence across the country but we saw
scant media coverage we're here these
states are responsible for policing
their streets the governor's the mayor's
are responsible for ensuring that our
streets are safe that it's already true
are protected and what we have seen is
in far too many Democrat run states and
Democrat run cities we have seen
violence and chaos right nothing like
and whereas coronavirus raging again is
that in red states or in blue states
Kelly and Serge the National Guard
Chicago for instance we saw over 100
people were shot and 14 tragically
killed and so this is them coming out
swinging as people are saying they have
Trump has nothing to run on so all they
can do is say but there are still
instances of violence in the United
States okay so then we should reelect
Trump what are we stupid many of us are
who worked as a barber and our hearts
break for this family also in Democrat
Ron New York City we saw that the New
York Post reported that there was one
shooting per hour this Saturday
absolutely inexcusable with 24 people
shot on Saturday alone and then and how
does this justify reelecting Trump Kayle
remind us about that zone otherwise
known as chop CH o P one person was shot
and killed in this autonomous zone run
by radical anarchists most you know we
saw another shooting there yesterday as
well and Democrats mayor of the city
called chop quote the summer of love but
it has been nothing of this sort clearly
with two individuals shot one person
shot and killed it is the responsibility
of governor's to protect their states to
police their streets guys just as a
heads up if you're in my audience and
this is resonating with you we really
should talk about critical thinking and
epistemology we really do because this
is you are being propagandized too right
now I hope no one in my audience right
now there's about 5,000 people watching
across our different platforms if this
is resonating with you we've got to have
a conversation and soon
most it's sad and it is shameful and
with that I'll take questions Wow no he
has not directed that and in fact I
would note that you wanna first we
continue to test about 500,000 per day
about half a million people per day 1.8
billion dollars is invested in NIH to
find new testing capabilities I mean
everything going on she comes out and
speaks for two minutes about the fact
that some cities continue to have gun
violence problems
that's the presentation that's the full
if Trump said I mean the president was
trying to expose what the media
oftentimes does is they ignore the fact
that the United States has more cases
because we doesn't go here interesting
we are leading the world in testing
that's in case pointing that out that
it's a fact that the media readily
ignores it was a comment that he made
and Jess it's common that he made in
passing there was not a yes to the media
coverage and pointing out the fact that
the me I was wondering if they'd have
better talking points by today but
they're just repeating the same failed
ones that's not a good sign for that to
joke about virus when he was not joking
about coronavirus you just said it was
joking about the media and their failure
to notice the fact that when you test
more you also find more cases of urgent
way
allocation of federal funding that's
already been dedicated to national test
every president of the way to make us
the leading country in the world on
testing that's a lot back the FDA is
authorized 144 tests under EU A's
emergency use authorization z0 122
molecular tests 21 antibody tests one
antigen test guess what the president
has led the way and making us the
world's leader when it's alive I just
mention the 1.8 billion at NIH that's
the never exploring new testing we're
leading the world and testing it'll
continue to do so
last July President Trump declared
himself the least racist person there
anywhere in the world why does he use
racist phrases let me go to my hungry
president doesn't what the President
does do influence fact that the origin
of the virus is China it's a fair thing
to point out as China tries to
ridiculously kung flu is racist three
ridiculously blame the corona virus by
the way many states have almost no cases
at this point the issue is not China
it's bad leadership in red states like
Arizona and Florida and Florida and all
of these places he's linking it to its
place of origin discrimination she's a
friend of the show by the way clearly
it's important that we totally protect
our Asian community in the US and all
around the world they're amazing people
and the spreading of the virus is not
their fault in any way shape or form
they're working closely with us to get
rid of it we will prevail together it's
very important so it's not a discussion
about Asian Americans who the president
values and prizes as citizens of this
great country it is an indictment guys
it's really bad they are they are on the
defensive they are really on the
defensive here media blames President
Trump for using the terms China virus
and Wuhan virus know kung flu k li kung
flu is these very terms the New York
Times called it the Chinese coronavirus
Reuters the Chinese virus see the de New
York Times right about kung flu Kaylee
can impose January 21st Chinese
coronavirus
more than a dozen other examples
categorically tongue flu is extremely
offensive to many people in the
asian-american community to be clear are
you saying the White House does not
believe it is race it to be clear I
think the media is trying to no answer a
games with the terminology of this virus
where the focus Trump called it come flu
the media is trying to play games
understand that one folks
roundly now condemns has been used by
the media I can go more examples Wuhan
virus CNN said on January 22nd I mean we
can go on and on and on so let me guess
PBS newshour called it the Kong flu
Kaley and a focus on action yes the
president of the Attorney General over
the weekend offered different
explanations behind every moment he was
attorney from South District of New York
can you clarify now why Burma was
dismissed and if it was at the
President's request well I think that
they were very much in sync this weekend
bar said Trump fired and Crump said I
didn't here's what happened the
president held mr. Clayton in very high
regard wanted to nominate him to this
position and sdn why to keep him in the
government as he returns to New York
Barr was working on a smooth transition
and when Berman chose to respond in the
way that he did that he came to the
president and the president agreed and
fired this individual mr. Berman as mr.
Clayton now will in time gets that
position being dismissed in the first
place because mr. Clayton wanted to go
back to New York City we wanted to keep
him in government and therefore he was
given the position at st NY but why is
the president I have two questions but
why did the president say
was involved in the firing of Jeff
Berman when they wanted to go back to
New York City we wanted to keep him in
government and but why did the president
have two questions but why did the
president say he wasn't involved in the
firing of Jeff Berman when the Attorney
General said he the president was the
one who fired them the Attorney General
was taking the lead on this matter he
did come to the president and report to
him when mr. Berman decided not to leave
and at that point is when the president
agreed with the decision of the Attorney
General and that to fire mr. Berman and
to promote mr. clay who was involved in
it that he was involved in the sign off
capacity he was not need AG Barr was
leading the way but in a sign-off
capacity yes the president was so my
second question on testing is you said
the president made that comment and just
about having people slow down the
testing the vice president just said
that it was made in passing with Pierre
de barros that it was tongue-in-cheek
but when the President himself was just
asked by a reporter like an hour ago he
said oh you did not say that he was just
joking when he said that he told us to
slow down the testing the president said
used that opportunity to extol the fact
that we've done more than 25 million
tests tool that we're finding more
people because we're doing more testing
and I would note that what the vice
president said in Peter Navarro whether
it's ingest and passing or
tongue-in-cheek those are all synonymous
crystal dishonesty and I know two
volvo-bg I don't even have to answer
this the media has never called it they
come flu
Chinese cars and calling it to come flu
are very driven media the media and your
networks specifically call it the media
and your networks specifically have
repeatedly use the term China virus
that's a known virus II and then gone on
to derive the resident as somehow using
a term that day that had themselves have
never used so we can go through CNS is
there anything I'd be more than happy to
go through CNN's history on February 9th
you guys talked about the Wuhan
coronavirus on January 23rd you guys
talked about the Luhan coronavirus 22nd
virus I can write it all out for you
calling it's a detail of for you and
it's not gonna it's not the same thing
as our first one is following what
you're just talking about with Furman so
obviously the president made the
decision to nominate into the job and
that was the verdict kerfuffle that we
saw over the weekend but there's this
decision to give to remove Berman from
the post before claim was nominated
before Clayton was either nominated or
more importantly confirmed and so I
think the question is why did you take
the acting
US Attorney out of this job before there
was a Senate confirmable place because
there's an intent to put Clayton there
and so there will be an interim
individual and acting attorney as we
work to get mr. Clayton in that position
yes I guess the question is why didn't
he continue in this position I am asking
because we are hopeful that Clayton will
be confirmed we're not leaving him there
we're putting an interim person in place
no investigation will be in fact
affected by this as was made clear by
attorney general Barr the president of
the weekends that the heat didn't impose
sanctions on China over the weaker
internment camps because it was worried
about his ability to negotiate the trade
deal but since the trade deal was signed
in January China as you mentioned
earlier not only has acted in ways that
you frustrated with on coronavirus but
the president has announced our behavior
in Hong Kong and they failed to live up
to many other tenants of the trade deal
itself at the same time the President
signed an executive order on a national
religious liberty so I'm wondering when
if ever is president actually going to
sanction China officials under either
they the original legislation or the
legislation he signed last week I'll get
an update for you on that but what I
will say so far is then you noted this
and your question that he's signed
legislation to hold China accountable
for the treatment for their treatment of
the we Gers and other minorities in
China but he also previously has imposed
visa restrictions on Chinese officials
for roles in China's treatment of
Leaguers and other minorities he's
blacklisted companies that were
complicit in China's treatment he has
taken strong action but I will get back
to you on that yes happy with the size
of the crowd in Tulsa
the president was very pleased with the
rally I was with him and I just have to
say these media reports on that he was
somehow furious on the plane there there
is no grounding in fact I was with him
on marine one on the waist area solvent
on marine one after he was very very
pleased with how the rally went the
media reporting on this prompted me to
go around and ask some of my colleagues
if they saw something different and I
spoke with dance Covino who was in the
Beast with the president everybody in
City was very energized having been
around the American people he was so I
he's quite pleased important not to
mistake being manic versus being pleased
with the turnout
pundants wrote to him that it was one of
the way the word is pundit not pundants
you'd think she would know that goes his
own humanity when he described the
wonderful West Point story the speech
made his message so clear and compelling
that no one could possibly have missed
it and it was so great to be out of the
swamp and in the country and those
comments or how the president feels to
do any maintenance to these events like
have more outdoor events where people
are clumped together or what's been
pumping so let me know to future rallies
I'd refer you to the campaign
yeah like tomorrow yeah thanks so much
guys I want to ask the chronovisor
who is the most senior person at this
time who is focused full-time on
coronavirus with no other duties simply
Corona Byers you're gonna come out who
would that person be and what type of
what type of authority does this person
have to spend u.s. resources so in the
Trump administration we're quite good at
doing two things at once we're expected
to do many things
that's where no one's president is
continuing to me the task force they
meet regularly doctor Falchi is there
dr. Burks is there dr. Redfield is there
there regularly talking to governor's
they had a governor's call today the
president is regularly briefed about
nobody is regularly involved in decision
making as we move forward there see if
there is there a specific person who is
focused on this full
with no other duties there a lot of
people are focused on this for senior
person without dr. Redfield dr. Burks
dr. Fauci all of our experts are
involved the vice-president every day
but we do many things at once in this
administration and we've done quite a
good job with coronavirus and it's um
we're pleased to see that it's a tragedy
any time a life is lost to coronavirus
but we're pleased to see that yesterday
for the first time there were under 300
fatalities so we are trending in the
right direction we're aware when there
are rises here and there and are you
because you're holding rallies to go in
to handle to put out and to save as many
lives as possible and thanks president
Trump could have lost three million
lives but we lost far nowhere three
million president Trump took action
early you guys know that they've never
mentioned three now three million is the
bar on Venezuela but first I just wanted
to follow up very quickly on regis
question and
kaitlin's follow does the president
regret using the term come flu
regardless of the fact that
your organization's including my own
have early on described the virus as the
woman virus that is eight different
things and same come flu does the
president regret using that term the
president never regrets putting the onus
back on China pointing out that China is
responsible for this and in the process
standing up for US troops look we're
being blamed by China and a campaign of
misinformation and I'm Venezuela who
does the president consider to be the
legitimate leader of Venezuela and is he
still interested in any form in meeting
with President Nicolas Maduro yeah very
glad you asked this question the
president tweeted today that unlike the
radical left I will always stand against
socialism and with the people of
Venezuela my administration has always
stood on the side of freedom and liberty
and against the aggressive Maduro regime
nothing has changed he continues to
recognize Juan glide oh as the leader of
Venezuela John Bolton has completely
discredited him himself
multiple senior administration officials
are on the record exposing his lies and
even the media seems to have taken note
of John Bolton I mean how ridiculous
some of the things he said the reviews
that his book have gotten has gotten
I've been rightly yeah right people on
Amazon said bad things about the book
exceedingly tedious and slightly
unhinged bloated with self-importance
that was the New York Times The New
Yorker said he takes an inflated view of
himself in a willingness to blame others
for just about everything
the Federalists talked about the
numerous serious factual flaws which
have been underlined as being false by
Pompeo light hyzer and others who have
all come down you can trust people full
of mistruths
about themselves and about the media
certainly about the president does he
claim that that was untrue
yes okay we thank you very much just I
wanted to go back to the SP my and and
Berman was Jeffrey Berman fire because
of investigations that he had overseen
in the president Trump's associates
including Rudy Giuliani and Michael
Cohen
what's him by her because he had
overseen those investigation no he was
not
and as I noted earlier an Ag bar noted
this will not disrupt the case is being
handled by the district which will
proceed as normal it is the president of
the White House not at least concerned
about the appearance of impropriety nope
in the firing given that those cases
were in handled in his office the
administration has very clearly outlined
the reason that he is leaving and it is
because mr. Clayton will be moved into
that role Morgan thanks Kaylee um it's
the way I was concerned about the fact
that foreign virus cases are now entire
thing on national basis after having
class
and I think it's a very important
question you're asking yeah and what I
would notice the fatality numbers and
we're pleased to see that number coming
down I would also point out that dr.
Burks said to me that a higher number of
these cases are less severe cases per
positive then at the beginning of this
pandemic because what's happening is
because of our extraordinary work with
testing we're able to identify cases in
the community before they develop
symptoms and are in a hospital so
instead of identifying cases and
hospitals we're identifying them in the
community which is a really good and
positive development and we are equipped
to handle when we see these embers that
have occurred the president is attacked
the move to remove Confederate statues
across the country he said that they
were it was an assault on quote our
heritage what if the White House and the
president say to Americans who find it
offensive to glorify people who owned
other Americans including enslaved
African Americans so I would note on
statues that what we're seeing across
the country is is really quite confusing
because you're seeing statues to face
like Gandhi statue to faced and ulysses
s grant statues face and abolitionist
Baldwin statue to face at the same time
we're being told that George Washington
statute needs to come down and Thomas
Jefferson statue needs to come down
where do you draw the line
you know from Gandhi all the way to
George Washington and it seems the
American people very much agree with the
President on this I'm not bringing down
these statues less than a third of those
polled according to morning consult
think these statues should be taken down
61 percent opposed it according to Maris
62 percent her answer is like a gift
Gallup touching on everything other than
the question and I would say that I when
people watch the statue to face mints
and the beheading of some of these
statues like Christopher Columbus where
do you draw the line because apparently
the line goes all the way to Gandhi so
this
I'm sorry my second question is going
back to the issue of kungfu
I spoke to Kelly on Conway when in March
she said that it was highly offensive
and wrong to use that term yes does the
president agree with Kelly and Collier
is he now saying that that term is not
highly offensive and all you look at
that was Kelly and colleagues own words
think um who is wrong President does not
believe it's offensive to note that this
virus came from China and to stand up
for a US military who China was active
effort to completely defame and that is
unacceptable to the are you saying that
she was wrong to say that Chanel she was
golden and his book if he goes on
prosecuted does the administration feel
that this would set or does it fear that
this would set precedent or embolden
public servants to violate their oaths
to this nation for political purpose
absolutely that's the concern
information intelligence officials and
look you have NSA director Nakasone
saying that this could cause permanent
loss of a valuable
that's right Chanel thank you for the
question you're absolutely right we
should be really concerned about the
message that would be sent if John
Bolton weren't prosecuted um you have
another government officials saying that
unauthorized disclosure of this
information could reasonably be expected
to enable foreign threat actors this is
the seriousness with which we look at
this book and the NSC looks at this book
as they scan it for classified
information there's real damage that can
be done and for what for self-promotion
and publicity have I failed NSA director
he has not lost confidence at all in
that tweet some that I read to you very
clearly senator president put out this
morning the press briefing is reading of
tweets their fight for freedom and I
would also note how tough this president
has been on Maduro by recognizing wongu
I do and when you compare that to the
obama-biden administration you had the
former Vice President Joe Biden who
actually met with the Venezuelan
dictator Nicolas Maduro and complemented
his hair according to Yahoo News if I
had your hair I think that the oin
person isn't allowed to bring in her own
chair so I would expect to see her
sitting on a yoga ball tomorrow which
she might actually inflate after she
gets into the room sanctions according
to a 2017 Miami Herald reports so when
you compare the actions of this
president we've stood against socialism
and on the side of freedom and finally
one thing that I just want to point out
that was handed to me Wow a whopping
seven point seven million total viewers
turn tuned in to Fox News to watch the
rally on Saturday nights yes no too much
made-up they watched it on TV
oh my god she actually seemed flustered
this time because I mean it's like how
could you can't possibly defend any of
what's going on any of this is even
remotely defensible at this point thank
you to everybody who watched with me
hello speaking of numbers we sometimes
get more people watching some of these
events on our stream than the number
that actually watch on the official
streams which which is crazy
speaking of ratings but but I don't I
don't typically take take the same
approach all right folks who want to
check out my strawberry video it is on
my Instagram it is also now on YouTube
remember that you can now book me on
cameo at cameo dot-com slash David
Pakman I'm getting some hilarious
requests and I will continue pumping
them out so to speak
I will also be streaming the Trump rally
tomorrow night so if you want to join me
for that just to be notified make sure
to follow if you're watching on Twitch
make sure to subscribe if you're
watching on YouTube it's free and that
way tomorrow when I go live with the
whacked-out Trump Corona rally in new
global hot spot Arizona the global hot
spot is now Arizona
that's where Trump is going to hold a
rally tomorrow night that'll be tomorrow
night okay guys I'll see you then and
thanks for joining me today
you